autre émana géraldine calme moi tout ça
ma chérie je trouve qu'on les a on les a
suffisamment à chaque fois un peu
stigmatiser la grande distribution
pour le coup la trouvais qu'ils sont
absolument exemplaire
vous avez parlé d'intermarché il ya
leclerc aussi qu'il va mettre entre 40
et 50 centimes le masque en fait alors
de deux choses d'entraînement formidable
d'émulation aimé et juste juste pour
l'anecdote parce que évidemment il faut
aussi il va partir mais trouver
commandes et quand même fou vous savez
qu'il ya aussi le luxe qui va faire des
masques et laura débat les gens qui
veulent dépenser beaucoup nation par
exemple la fjfnb pour d'autres marques
fendi parents pleins à 490 euros qui est
déjà sold out aux et en italique
voilà c'est n'importe quoi en fait c'est
les masques on appelle la cdma tickets
spéciaux anti antico vide mais sinon
c'était la mode dans la fashion week
quand il ya la fashion-week juste
dallaire il ya eu d'ailleurs à mon avis
qui a été un gros foyers de propagation
aussi du virus est là il mettait les
masques anti-pollution que faisait les
créateurs effectivement les créateurs
ont aussi inventé des masques un peu
luxe contre contre le collier voilà mais
moi je fais d'accord avec raymond c'est
pas scandaleux si après tout s'il ya des
gens au très très riches qui ont envie
d'acheter des masques très très très
très cher et l'économie
la fée des emplois mais qu'est ce qu'on
s'en fout google répond un point de vue
j'ai vu des masses comme toi géraldine
d'autres d'une autre marque j'ai vu des
matches qui sont montés à 700 euros
quand tu mets 500 euros devant ta bouche
3° de deggo il est ou pour mettre 700
balle devant ta bouche pour protéger
alors un degré de cohérence c'est de
dire qui regarde moi je peux mettre un
masque vit-on samedi donne une fois de
plus je vais être démago à 700 balle
fait autre chose avec les 700 bat mais
ça veut dire regarde moi je suis
vraiment ces gens là je les ai vomi
mais je n'ai jamais roulé des emplois il
fait marcher son petit chercheur et
banca déjà il y eut d un monde qui n'est
pas le nôtre qui l'a jamais on ne crée
pas de notre bord